Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now,
(time for some deep sh*t)
I find myself alone,
in the ocean.
I find myself wandering,
adrift,
choking,
in the crushing depths,
and the cold loneliness
of the empty abyss below me.
And you may be thinking to your self: Oh no.
Karen: Emergency. 10 seconds of oxygen remaining*
I'm about to run out of oxygen. (oops ^_^)
But, no!
I was actually smart about this.
I-
got my save file,
*haughty voice* and brought it with me all the way back to Cincinnati.
And therefore, I know exactly what I'm going to be doing in the future.
HAHAHAHAHA
(Dracuplier) I bet I scared you.
huhu
So,
I'm going to be a bit more CALM and quiet in this one
just because my voice is still not a 100%
It wasn- it wasn't good, to immediately come back into recording,
*coughs* and start screaming in a horror game.
(Mark plz get better)
But!
Fortunately,
*click*
I have a plan.
So I've left the safety of my other base
and as you can see, my sub- *stutter* my, my, my seamoth is right here,
but my seamoth has run out of power.
(oopsie)
I'll fix that in a second.
But I've got some messages here
that I'm going to read now
and then put them
in a future locker, when I make my new base
on the edge of the grand reef,
which is where I'm going to be going next.
so
first off
you dang said adjacent to the kelp
forest there should be a large wreck in the grand
reef where you can find bio-reactor
fragments. Also,
in the deep grand reef you can find the Degassi
crew's last base where
you can find alien
containment chamber fragments
which is what I'm going to be looking for
in the next adventure
down into the dark, inactive
lava zone. But,
unfortunately,  I thought I could do that
with the PRAWN suit but, eliteheadhunter4
says : "The PRAWN suit right
now is about as useful as a sandpaper
dildo." (o geezers) Which doesn't sound pleasant
in any capacity not that I've a vast
experience with dildos.
Uh. And then TheCrimsonSoldier says:
"Mark, scan the glass hallways and parts of the
base that you don't got specs for."
Which is something that I have not been doing so
thank you for that recommendation, and I will be doing
that when I get down to the Degalalalalallala
(markiplier.exe has stopped working)
lalalalallalalallala (mark has a stroke)- When I get down to the Degassi's
last base, which is a
very interesting idea that they were *inhale* able
to go deeper and deeper into the
ocean. They went down to...
from the safety of the island which I dunno why
why they would have left the island
to the purpleish
area that was even deeper and then
down to the grand reef which is even
deeper than they were once. Why did
they keep getting pushed deeper and
deeper into the ocean? Why didn't they find
safety up above the ocean?
Or maybe the topography
changed, the tides changed,
maybe there was times when
the ocean rose and sank with
the coming and going of the tides.
But why also did they not
go for the alien technology
that was on the other island?
Now, it's not an illusion
that the technology "wasn't there" like
we've been playing in the game. When they add
stuff - this thing is really drifting-
when they add stuff,
it's as if it was always there.
Anyway,  I
fixed this thing up by the way, I fixed it and there have
been some messages *PLAYING MESSAGE*
Nooo.
Uh huh.
Okay.
So that's interesting, that means theres a rescue
ship on the way that's
gonna take about a week to get here depending
on whether or not they actually decide
we're worth the trouble. I don't have a means
of getting a signal out to them so the
only thing I can hope to do is
deactivate the alien
gun before they arrive.
Now, I don't know when exactly they're going to be
arriving, but to get to that, I need to get
down to the alien fragments
down at the Degassi crew
base. Now I have some stuff with
me, I have - uh, a
rotten lantern fruit, some power cells, these
ion crystals which are
the SAAAME power
as an atomic
bomb - no wait, was it,
was it,  did it say it was the, the power
of the sun in the pocket of my hand?
Either way,  not pleasant
for me to hold around, and probably
radioactive (ouchies) eh-eh-unless these aliens
have figured out a way to create energy
without extreme amounts of radioactivity
going on. But either way,
not important to me, I have other plans.
Thanks Karen, thanks for taking a nap on
me when I need to do the most. So what we have
to do is we have to get down to the base there
and then build a base as
close as possible
to the edge of the reef. And then,
we'll build a moon pool
to be able to build more- wooh, you guys are big-
I still have to build a base on the back of
you someday. I'm gonna do that.
You're not gonna stop me from doing
that. Anyway,  if we're gonna build
the base as close to the edge of the grand reef
as we possibly can, and then take
that down into the depths
and hopefully, when we build the
moon pool nearby, and I've
let my water and health go
to waste, but I'm not going to worry about
that because I have the means with which to
do something about that. Ooh my
God-
I fricken hate that
eeeuu don't think I need to go down there
but i think this is gonna lead me to the grand reef
*Loud rumbling*
hello... okay, hi...
(annyeonghaseo ;P)
that was weird
what the hell were those sounds? Eeh...
either i'm hearing things I've never heard before
or we are in something new here
There is a- I know- I know there is an entrance
to the inactive lava zone somewhere around here
so long as I can find a relatively appropriate
place for a base... which might be on the edge
-holy shit that's a new sound?!
(Markimoo waits for imminent death)
okay?
I apologise in advance if I scream like a little girl
because it's gonna- it's gonna peak the shit out of this microphone right now
(You're forgiven)
And I know that's not gonna be pleasant
And I'm gonna try keep it relatively calm
as I explore the depths of this ocean
I find it's infinite wonders
A constant reminder of how small I really am
So what I need to do is I need to build
and quickly, which means I need to gather materials
and quickly, 'cause I don't have enough
Well, that's not what I need- that's not gonna help me at all
can I get some goddamn titanium?
do you guys not even have titanium?
I can't build a base out of goddamn gold, now can I?
Whoa, hey buddies
ooh, it's the sea treaders
hey friends, how're you doing down there?
oh geez, I got all the warnings going off
yeah- I probably should've gathered materials before I came out here
but then again I'm dumb
I'm gonna go do that
yeah, I know
I'm gonna save that food block for a little later
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna be back right quick
and I'm gonna go gather some materials
because I'm gonna need them to be able to build this thing
because I do not have enough
I know that for a fact
If I had...
my prawnsuit, with the right attachment
maybe I would have a chance
But I don't
man, but ever- whoa, what is that?
whoa
oh, cool! I need that!
it's the power cell charger fragment
which means that i'm gonna be able to actually charge my power cells
which is awfully useful- oh my god
I have never seen this area before
so I honestly don't know what to expect out of it
but i'm gonna check the, uh, the deposits real quick
i get it
titanium, yes- okay, so this is what i need
I don't have my rebreather
and I'm aware
okay
I know, I know, I know, I know
titanium? oh my god, they're so tiny!
they're tiny!
oh, hello! :3
*giggles*
hello!
oh, I'm like a child
where is my goddamn sea moth??
OOOOH, where's my sea- oh god
you hold still for just a second just before you start
drifting off again. maybe now that I repaired it I can just pilot it
*PLAYING MESSAGE*
ya?
Uh-huh
Well thanks for keeping it positive for us
do appreciate all the, y'know,
wonderful news that you're bringing along
And welcome back everybody.
I know I went on a little bit of a misadventure there
but I realised that I needed to shift gears in exactly what I was doing.
see... I've got a lot of ambition here
but I don't have absolutely everything I need
and there's one place I have not gone yet
Then again, there are many places that I have yet to go
but there is one place that has just a hint of danger
that I need to go to
where there's a lot
of resources
and scannables that I need to find
and they exist, in both the floating island zone
and the dunes.
And the sand dunes are particularly dangerous
because I know there's a great many reaper leviathans
and I've been told that there may even be more
reaper leviathans than I previously encountered.
And I need to make a quick pitstop because I need some table coral
for a computer chip that I'm gonna need
whenever I make my second base.
and I'll do that in a bit, but I just needed two pieces for that.
So the rest of this is just an opportunity for me to go out
Into the great beyond with which I have not yet explored
And see-
What lies in the darkness for me.
'Cuz I know there are wrecks
Oh, I know there's a great many wrecks.
And there are new things that have been added
that I have yet to see.
And I will find them.
*Creature noise*
Oooooh that's- that's a bad sound.
Is that a scannable or is that just an exploded piece?
Excuse you!
I hope you broke a tooth.
Don't try it again buddy you'll lose.
It is.
But I already have that. Damn it.
Alright...
Okay...
I see you.
Oh I see you.
Oh I see you!
So you had a lot of things and I-
Oh shit. Stop doing that.
Jeez, you did have a lot of things
So this was a- this would have been a good place to go
for the mobile vehicle bay.
And rescue Billy, Samwise- Oh no...
Billy, Jeffrey, Samwise and Marshal. I'm sorry sons.
It's just that I don't care.
(wonderful father)
Oh boy. Okay. We good?
Oh!
Well you're a little far off from where you're suppose to be.
Oh my God.
Are you?
Maybe I'm far off from where I'm- *Creature growl*
Eh- eh- eh *Nervous laughter*
Nope, you're exactly where you need to be aren't you?
'Cuz you're right by the float- sorry
-you're right by the floating islands.
And upon the floating islands bridged across the back
Of two of you.
I know for a fact
is
another wreck
And I have a funny feeling I'm staring at it right in the face.
Oh yes I am.
Hello, hello friend
You're gonna tell me exactly what I need to know.
You're gonna show me.
Exactly how I make
What I need to make. Is that a bit of a propulsion cannon?
Oh yes please.
Thank you! Got that. Hey, hell yeah I got that!
That was quick. And then I'll - ow -
God dammit, stop bashing me!
I mean, I know that was probably my fault but
I don't have insurance so I can't make a claim to that.
Let's fix me back up a bit
Oh, those are bad sounds!
Oh that sounds terrible!
Okay, alright then.....Yeesh
So there's a lot of areas like this that I have not yet explored and I will very soon.
I'm just gonna go in and see
Ca-chunk!
I've never even opened a door like this!
Well, shit.
*reads* Erosion patterns on the landmasses
suspended here suggest they once floated on the surface......
Floated on the surface, you mean -
Woah, what is that?
Statis rifle, hell yes!
So these floating islands were once, like, the giant floating island.
In that they were a floating island but now they're just kinda sinking a little bit because the
The, the girthy bubble balls
seem to be running out of
y'know
juice
Come on, you'd better hurry up, I'm running out of air here
Oh jeez, come onnnnn...
Come on...
Come on.
Better be something good behind this.
Woo! What is that?
Ooh.
"Don't climb on or get off this equipment"
Prawn?
Wait, there's something for the P.R.A.W.N. in here!
I gotta go, I gotta go *racecar noises*
gotta go! gotta go! gotta go! (Hurry Mark!)
Eee! Eee! Eee! Eee!
Aaaaand pit stop.
(BREATHES DEEPPPP)
Yes, I feel much better now
but there's something for the P.R.A.W.N in here.
So I gotta find out exactly what's going on here.
There's another stasis rifle piece
but if there's a piece for the P.R.A.W.N.
to get to its grappling arm, I am going to take that P.R.A.W.N.
everywhere with me.
Oh! It's a P.R.A.W.N. suit!
Well that's not going to help me...
Thought my inventory would have been full...
What is that...
I already have the propulsion cannon.
Did I get the stasis rifle? Probably.
P.R.A.W.N. suit fragment? Ehhhh.
Woah!
Grappling arm?
That sounds good!
Shit.
Only half of it.
Yep!
There's the other half.
Okay, but I thought - I thought it already came with the grappling arm.
Huh.
Now this is a pickle.
Grappling arm, stasis rifle...
Dammit, this one probably doesn't have what I need, I need to get out of here.
I need to go go go go go.
Yeah, could you stop screaming at me?
I've got enough to deal with right now.
Stop banging!
If you're banging on my Seamoth it does not want any!
Stop!
(NO MEANS NO!)
Asshole.
Ah yeah, this just leads to the P.R.A.W.N. room.
What is this? Got no signal there...
No signal there...
Whole lotta nothing...
Inventory full...
yeah.
There's nothing here for me
it doesn't have the drill bit on.
Which is what I NEED.
Yeah, just the grappling arm
and I've already got plenty of that.
So I just need to get out of here...
Yeesh x5
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know!
Stop banging on my Seamoth!
Stop it.
Alright.
So that answers my question in that
that answers where I need to go next, which is
an even more dangerous place than I've already been to.
Good God...
Alright, here comes the mushroom forest.
(the gooood sh*t)
Which I believe probably has another piece of technology that I don't yet...
possess, but oh.
Oh I know where I am.
Oh I know exactly where I am.
Oh I know exactly where I am...
I'm at the...
I'm at the mouth of the beast.
I'm at the, uh,
I'm at the entrance of the inactive lava zone, aren't I?
Oh, that seems bad and dark and bad and dark.
(Mark likes to say 'Yeesh' alot)
But I know there is a large...
*pause*
wreckage.
Around here somewhere.
*hisses* yeeeeee
I don't like it when whole areas don't load
because that's how these things creep up on me
Oh no.
Oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
N-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-o
Oh I see you
I see you, friend. I see you.
"Detecting multiple leviathan class lifeforms in the region.
Are you certain whatever you're doing is worth it?"
*chuckling* Yeah, I'm not so sure about that my-myself Karen.
Is what I told you guys about this ping
An incredibly dangerous area to just... flutter around in.
Because
There are
A lot of leviathans here.
*Cringing noise* And for good reason.
It does guard the entrance to this place,
where apparently the story
continues.
I see some littered bits- Oh! There it is.
Okay, good.
*Karen's voice* Caution, dehydration detected.
*Mark* Good thing I've got some water on me.
I do not have water on me,
why do I not have water on me,
I thought I had water on me,
why do I not have water on me?
This is bullshit.
Okay.
So this has now turned into a race against time.
*background noise of Karen warning*
Okay I can't go any farther down
But,
I'm willing to bet that there are,
some pieces down here that I need.
So I need to go now.
Yeeherha I don't like this
I don't like this at all.
There's gotta be pieces in here that I need.
There's just gotta be 'cause- does this door open?
Yes it can! Open up!
Open up!
Oh please tell me there's something in here that's good.
Ohh, thermal plant?
Well I guess that is good.
It's not exactly what I was looking for, but okay, I'll take it.
Shit, there's another one
Good, good, good, good, good, good..
Not that not that!
This is all full up... I've already had thermal fragment.
Reinforce dive suit, I guess that's good.
Okay! Good good good good good.
Ahh, I'm running out of time.
Shit.
Cuz not only am I running out of oxygen right now but I'm also running out of...
Yup.
Yup, yup, yup, I'm also running out of water.
And I don't know if I'm going to be able to get back
with the limited amount of water that I have.
Ah, shit, I got, uh, maybe one more try
I gotta go one more down.
One more dive and I gotta find it in this next batch.
I gotta find like a back entrance-
-I think there's another hole in there that's kinda like
the other one that I went into.
I just gotta make sure that I don't crush
And hope for the best.
Alright let's do this.
Yeesh that's not a good sign.
Please do not eat me.
Ahhh
Alright here we go.
Okay.
Don't even bother dude, don't even bother-
What is that?
Vehicle upgrade console?
That sounds good!
Okay there's one of 'em..
Shit I do not have time to cut down this full damn door.
Yeeee...
Cuz I- I gotta get back alive because
I've got a lot of things in my inventory that I don't think I've saved yet.
Yee...
I thought I had water
I thought I had tons of water.
Yes! Yes! Yes!
Not that! Not that!
Get the fuck out of my face!
Get-
Are you fucking kidding me?
Go!
Fucking go!
*Karen* Caution, 30 seconds of oxygen remaining.
*Mark* I can do this
I can do this
I can do this, I can do this, (r u sure bra?) I can do this, I can do this, I can do this, I can do this,
I'm out! I'm out! I'm out! I'm out, I'm out, I'm out
Out out out out out out out out out
Out!
Let me out!
Are you fucking kidding me... Let me out!
Are you kidding me..
Let me out.
Jesuuuuusss...
Oh oh oh oh oh oh
Oh boy I made it.
So I gotta book it back to the safe shallows.
And, uh,  get some water immediately because I do not have any.
But I got a thermal plant generator, I got the drill bit for the arm,
I've got everything that I needed so I should be okay.
Unless I...
Unless I have...
Hibitiy hibitiy hibity hibity hibity hibity
Gonna make it, gonna make it...
I'm gonna make it, guys.
Guys, I'm gonna make it!
It's gonna happen.
Oh boy
Oooh boy.
Oh boy.
Ohh, right down to the wire.
I also don't know why the life pod is so laggy.
Cuz lately the life pod has been just unbelievably laggy.
Like this is the frame rate that I'm getting out of this.
Okay, can you- wow- can you not?
Oh my god.
"Subject 11783 destroyed"?
"Mode switch: patrol." ?
What does that even mean?
What?
Oh, geeze...
Oh why is it so laggy here?
Uh, we did what we set out to accomplish
We've got the drill bit,
We can get the prawn suit down into the deep areas,
We can actually mine enough resources to be able to build a base very quickly down there.
And then we should be able to do, exactly what we need to do,
with just a little preparation.
I'll be able to get a base down in the deep depths
of the grand reef.
And then create,
a base to go see the last base of the Degassi,
get the alien fragments, and then go down into the inactive lava zone,
and see what the hell is up down there.
So either way, *interrupted by dehydration warnings*
Ugh.
I know, Karen, thank you.
*Blows kiss* I love you, thanks for taking care of me.
(Better than Jack?)
And thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you,
in the next video.
Buh-bye!
Have a nice day!